listen Lily we gotta talk about it the
bangs Okay the banks
were you so shocked when they wrote your
bangs into the script for this season
yeah so last season before two came out
we were doing a press tour like this and
I came downstairs to be in a room with
her and I had cut bangs because it's
something I'd always wanted to do and I
was like you know what if not now when
then I kept them and then Darren and our
director Andy Fleming who's been with us
in season one were like do you plan on
keeping them and I was like yes I do so
we were like let's write it into the
first episode right away it's Gotta
happen and we're gonna make it part of
the storyline because as I can attest to
I have changed my hair when I felt like
I've changed my life and it felt like
the perfect opportunity after getting to
know Emily season one and two so much as
who she was she's established she can
switch it up season three and it's
justifiable in the story and then we got
to keep it and so I was so excited
except when you came down with bangs as
Lily I had the opposite a reaction I was
like oh my God yeah yeah
listen bangs are life-changing okay like
and yes if you want to change your life
change your hair
that absolutely goes like that okay so
Ashley listen your girl Emily has kind
of hit a Crossroads in season three she
kind of has to decide between Madeline
or Sylvie let me ask you this if you had
to work for one of these incredible
women who would it be
why am I gonna watch it
I think I would I mean I think I would
choose to
um I would want to stay living in Paris
um
yeah so I think it would be I think it'd
be working for silby but honestly I
would die to see scenes with you in cave
um
Ashley oh yeah amazing amazing okay to
me what about you Madeline or Sylvie
as my character asked Camille the person
as as
a character as my character definitely
will be um
oh Mindy would not work for either of
them what are you talking about Mindy
would be like let's just make our own
company you and Sylvie together oh my
God
and I'd walk straight out I'd be like
these girls I don't even know what I
would say I'd be so intimidated yes
I don't work for lvmh or jvme yeah
I love that okay listen Lily and Ashley
you two have such a beautiful special
friendship not only on camera but off
camera and I'm curious to know how do
you think these two very different
characters you know help build each
other up and and what do they bring out
of each other
oh my gosh I mean we heard it in season
two when Emily was having a problem and
talking about on the bench with Mindy
she says
um stop talking about what you should do
and focus on what you want and what you
need and I feel like Ashley has also had
those conversations with me where I can
get so much in my head and worrying so
much that you she brings me back to my
core and allows me to sit and think in
silence and just know that my own
feelings and thoughts are enough of a
reason to justify making an action or a
decision and I feel like that's what
Emily and has learned from Mindy as well
um well I think also like and you know
with all of us but I've especially felt
is I feel like there's just never been a
moment where
um it hasn't been a given that we're
uplifting each other
um and sometimes that means calling
somebody out you know but in terms of
the character but I think it's so funny
I think we're uh especially like how we
grew up
we are kind of sold this like fairy tale
of like you're gonna one day find your
soul mate and a partner you're gonna one
day find the love of your life in that
and then like I've had more and more of
these you know friendships but
especially with Lily of just
oh my gosh I didn't even realize my soul
mate could be like a friend as well you
know I think that's what we find in the
story as and it's a it's very special
that's incredible yeah